(rock music)
(cheering)
- The first time I laid
down the guitar track
and then played the fiddle on top of this,
it make me have goose bump on my arm,
'cause like this is something shamanic.
(rock music)
My name's Nature
Ganganbaigal; I am a musician.
I'm originally from China, but
I have a Mongolian ancestry.
(mournful fiddle music)
So this our Mongolian fiddle,
we call them (speaking foreign language),
or in the English we can
say horsehead fiddle.
(fiddle music)
(throat singing)
Throat singing is a very ancient
and traditional way of singing.
You press your throat, and
you generate one sound,
but then you generate an overtone
on the top of it, within your mouth,
so it sounds like two
sounds at the same time.
(fiddle music)
(throat singing)
With the next song, I'll
ask you first one question:
who ride a horse before?
(cheering)
If you read the Mongolian history,
it's all about those brave warrior conquer
all around the world and
then they don't fear death.
You know, that kind of spirit.
(wordless vocalizing)
(rock music)
Metal people, heavy metal
people, it's also like,
very, mentally, you don't give a shit,
you just do whatever you want.
Like this free spirit,
definitely free spirit in it.
(rock music)
People will say, "Oh, why you
are doing Mongolian music?"
They don't understand
the whole ancestry thing.
They don't understand your
own cultural identity.
But at the end of the day, I
love the Mongolian culture.
And that's all what it matters.
(rock music)
(cheering)
Thank you!